hi my name is Nick a deer and my
question to the economic lawrence is
though what is it there it's actually
going to do after he's actually got the
Nobel Prize because it's all well and
good having a Nobel Prize but that
doesn't mean there should be a degrading
of the quality of research and also
teaching I think it's really important
to find out what are the next steps of
what's the next progress and they're
going to make after winning the Nobel
Prize it of course changes your life in
the short run and the longer run i'll
pick up on projects that i have been
working on and continue to do soccer
that's what one does once you're in the
sort of business well my case is unusual
because i was nominated to being a
governor of the Federal Reserve System
before I won the Nobel Prize and I am
still hoping to get confirmed have that
job and then have the opportunity to do
research on the set of issues that
concern the fed monetary policy bank
regulation consumer protection and
avoiding the kind of financial meltdown
that we have experienced which is
referred to as dealing with systemic
risk I will continue teaching the same
courses I was teaching before and using
the same paying the same attention to
them updating them every year i hope i
have time to continue doing research so
though obviously the productivity falls
but not because of the noble but because
age unfortunately he takes it toll in
your brain but i will continue doing it
i hope that that's what happens with all
lawyers there is a temptation to say
things without thinking very much after
you know though because people listen to
you more and they think that what you
say is always correct but that's quite
wrong i think you should continue paying
as much attention to what you are doing
as you did before
you